uh okay
right now you are yep all right thank
you
okay before we get started on public
hearing
our um uh statement as chair of the
house transportation committee
i find it due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the token 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
his public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing with the
potential for executive session to occur
forever
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
uh and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that one
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meetings through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available on the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
two the notice for this meeting applies
to the pub schools rsa
91a three anyone who has a problem
accessing the media should call
603-271-3600
or email hcs ledge.state.nh
us four
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i'd like to introduce our staff brad
greenland thank you as always
uh please note that all votes are taken
all votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
so let's start by doing so uh my world
follow attendance and each member takes
their presence
please also state whether there was
anyone with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
all right good morning everyone
representative ankerberg
representative aaron uh representative
aaron is president in the community room
thank you good morning
representative perez representative
rice's president
in my house in milford and i'm here
along with my dog
and my rabbit thank you uh clerk
crawford is here representative brassy
there's representative grassy is here
and rochester at my home and i am alone
at the moment
thank you representative fox
i am present i'm in my home with my
husband
and a friend they are in another room
thank you vice chairman gagney
representative forsky
representative
representative hill senator hill is here
in our assigned committee room thank you
representative o'hara here in the
committee room
thank you representative pickering i'm
here
at my home in this room alone
thank you representative johnson here in
the committee room
thank you representative rich i'm here
at my home alone
representative smith
representative smith representative
stevens
in nashua no one in the room with me
thank you representative sykes
yes i'm i'm here at my home and no one
is on the front porch with me
thank you representative
morning i'm here in my home i do have
family members in my house
representative i'm here alone in my
office but my wife is in the house
thank you and chairman walsh here
okay before we get started
or representative o'hara don't have a
hard time
seeing these participants but i'm only
showing
members of the committee i can't seem to
get to
[Music]
who are you looking for
okay so i'm gonna open the public
hearing on an amendment to senate bill
131 fn the amendment number
is
h relative to the maximum weight of
motor vehicles chair recognizing
representatives
thank you mr chairman mr chairman i
introduce this amendment is relative to
the maximum
weight of motor vehicles which is
amending the bill by inserting it to
part six
this following new part part seven again
relative to the maximum weight of motor
vehicles
thanks for that
i'm supposed to speak longer so i can
get my uh
uh andrew player from the department of
safety state police
he just needs time
good morning thank you so
this this bill the department safety was
approached by
the timber new hampshire timber
association with concerns as far as uh
the commercial motor vehicles um
their particular industry in particular
wood chips out in the uh
the woods holding these types of types
of product out of the woods
um they were routinely having extra
weight on
what's called their drive axles they're
the two axles at the rear of a
tractor trailer where the trailer
hitches to the tractor um
due to due to in part of
there is availability to be the vehicles
to be weighed out in the woods
as as well as the uneven terrain and the
extra weight required
sometimes in order to get out of the
woods uh that they sought
a uh a change to the bill to allow
a an increase on those those types of
axles
for that particular commodity being
being carried i was something that they
uh they worked with on the
commissioner's office
uh troop g was uh asked for their input
on this as well whether it was
that the vehicles were capable of doing
this type of thing uh
it is our opinion that they are capable
they can't safely carry that type of
weight
i know that the new hampshire department
of transportation does have some
unattended consequences that they are
concerned about and they will i'm sure
they
someone from that agency will be
testifying following me
but uh this was a change like i say that
the uh
the commissioner's office did work with
with industry in order to try and
accommodate their particular concerns um
i'd be happy to answer any questions
that the committee members might have
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
representative this is actually simply a
question for the chair
can you just for all of us clarify that
this amendment is exactly the same
wording as hb
279 which um what went to the floor last
session it
is the exact language of 279
as amended by the committee that went to
the floor
last session thank you i just wanted to
make sure that there wasn't a minor
change i had missed i appreciate that
nope i had to ask ols to uh actually i
supplied them with the amendment number
for them to draft this amendment
uh any other questions from the
committee
seeing that thank you lieutenant thank
you
uh chair recognizes jason stock
who is in support of the bill
you just need something okay can you
hear me
good morning all right well thank you
good morning
um and for the record uh
this is i'm jason stock i'm the
executive director of the new hampshire
timberland owners
association our our membership we
represent
timberland owners we have about 1 300
members
landowners but also foresters loggers
forest products truckers and and of
course sawmills
um i'm pleased to come here today and
speak in support of sport of the
amendment
1442 and i i want to thank
chairman walsh for reintroducing it um
and as he confirmed this is basically
house bill 279
that passed this committee on a
bipartisan vote
back in february so
we we appreciate that that support we
got back in february i think it was a
13-6 vote
my recollection is correct so we
appreciate that
i wanted to take a few minutes and kind
of reiterate
from our perspective why we think this
is
why we think this is necessary and um
and then try to answer some of the
questions that have come up
um since the last hearing um
get recognizing that this is a very
narrow
piece of of legislation we're talking
about
raw forest products leaving a log
landing
all right so this is a raw forest
product leaving a log landing logs
and um and and wood chips
um and and so we're
we're looking as as
mr player had mentioned earlier when
you're loading
a commodity like wood chips or logs on a
log landing
there are quite a few variables that are
in play
you have terrain that is uneven
you have a for a product that is
variable
hardwood is is heavier than softwood
um wood chips when they're blown into
the back of a a trailer can
can pack in
and you also have have a seasonality of
it
if you're loading if you're loading uh
in winter obviously you're on frozen
ground
whereas a day like today if you're
loading it's the ground is softer
and so if you're on the crane loading a
truck
you're watching your suspension you're
watching how your
your load is getting is coming together
you know you watch your springs you
watch your air brakes you watch all
these things and
you know the the goal is to try and in
in the case of certified vehicles uh try
to become
as close to 99 000 gross vehicle weight
as you can
where it gets really tricky is is with
the axle weights and
in particular those drive axles those
tandem drive axles
right on under the tractor and so that's
that's where um we've seen consistently
that there's been
that there's been a problem um
particularly uh
as mr platon mentioned with chips when
you're blowing chips in
um contractors have tried all sorts of
tricks and and techniques to try and
and adjust for that and you know with
with limited success
the other piece is is that you don't
have the benefit of a scale
um again you're you're in you're in the
woods you you know unlike a facility
um you know where there's where there
are scales present you you don't
and and so these are these are
challenges that when you're out in the
woods
and you're loading the other piece that
i think is important
to bear in mind is that we're talking
about commodity products
you know and so the a response could be
well just
don't load as much go you know load the
truck half full and
and call it good well when you're
dealing with commodities
wood chips logs you know
transportation's a huge part of that
cost
and it's a it's a huge you know it's a
huge determinant
on the value of that wood and and and
the value
of that project so again contractors
try trying to you know they work the
endeavor to try to get close to that 99
and to the extent that they can hit the
axle weights they do
the other dynamic that we see in the
state
and actually within the and this is kind
of a more regional
approach is that we look and with some
of the
contraction we've seen in some of our
markets in recent years
specifically we've had some power plants
closed some wood chip power plants close
we've had there was a paper mill in
western maine that was lost
what we're finding is that these
commodities are having to travel
further they're having to cross state
lines as people are trying to find homes
for them
and so new hampshire's when we look at
you know a truck being loaded in new
hampshire um
you know that truck uh is
you know there is inconsistency i should
say for that truck when it enters
another state
and i'll i'll point to maine in
particular
um you know maine's their tandem
they they have they allow 46 000 pounds
um you can certify a vehicle to go as
high as 46 000 on a pair of tandems in
maine
um and so you know what happens is that
you have a vehicle
and again we're in a regional
marketplace where i'm i'm a trucker i'm
hauling off of a main
treat or excuse me i'm hauling off of a
new hampshire tree farm
um and i'm trying to move a commodity
let's say into a main market i'm
competing against maine markets and i'm
at
it at a disadvantage so
the whole point of this legislation was
one of the key points was to try to
provide
some consistency with our neighboring
states
and when a truck is loaded in one state
and it moves to another state such as
maine in particular
that we're consistent and so that you're
you're consistent when you cross those
across those lines and when you're
moving your your commodity
since the since the the february when
you heard this last
you know there were some concerns about
well
what about you know there were some
concerns raised about what about the
impact of bridges
well we you know say red list bridges or
e2 bridges
we're amending a part of the law rsa2
266 18 b um that's the
that's the statute where you're amending
the certified loads
for the certified load statute where
these vehicles
are they have to obtain a permit
to haul these loads those vehicles are
already
through that regis by virtue of that
registration and hauling those loads
they're already prohibited from and
restricted
on crossing those bridges so the concern
that
all right you're going to have a lot of
heavy trucks kind of going around
crossing these bridges there's already
checks in place
to prohibit that from happening it's
it's hardwired right into the statute
and the other piece is that i mean
i've spent quite a bit of time in in
recent weeks
really studying the weight limits and
trying to say all right
you know that one of the concerns is
well this is unprecedented it would
require a lot of
reinspection we're kind of creating a
new
category of of weight limits for these
tandem axles and
when i dove into rsa 266
18 b there are a couple examples that
jumped out at me that said you already
have
tandems out there on the highway um
through this
again through that through
226 18b that
that could be you know 40 000 pounds um
an example is a single unit
three axle um unit where you have
you can get it certified to go to a
gross vehicle weight of 65
000 pounds the
a single axle can weigh 22
400 you do the simple math and you say
all right
if those tandems on the back of that
single unit 3 axle
unit are greater than 40 inches apart
then at that point i'm i'm over 40 000
pounds on that
on those that rear tandem likewise i
look at a tri-axle
a single unit four axle so you have a
truck with a tri-axle in the back
again i can go i can get that weighed or
certified to go to 73
000 pounds so that leaves me and again
my single axle limit
on that is 20 000 pounds so that leaves
me 53
000 pounds on that tri-axle on the back
on the rear end of that truck
well the way the the current statutes
are written
i'm allowed no more than one of those
axles can haul more than 40
000 so again you take take it
take that 53 thousands split that up
you feasibly you can have a pair of
those
those axles in that tri-axle mix
um push you know you can have 40 000
pounds
so again this is i'm looking at this
again i spent quite a bit of time trying
to understand and decipher this but
we're not you know this is not
unprecedented
um and then the the final point that
a concern that had raised was well we're
making an exist
an exception for a special interest um
and you know i to that i say we already
have that
wired into our statutes statutes do that
already
and they do it to recognize the
uniqueness of a commodity
or a marketplace whether the commodity
is safe perishable
whether it's a a necessary something
necessary such as heating oil
things of that nature we see it with
with maple sap
milk and and when we look at our
neighboring states
you know we look at maine they have you
know they have already forest products
they they allow for for forest products
again higher weight limits and of course
in maine
potatoes as well so you see that
that is throughout the statute and again
it's to recognize
the uniqueness of the commodity the
circumstances in which it's being
harvested
hauled and kind of how it's how it's
being brought to market
again when i talk to my my members and i
talked to folks in and around this and
and we did i was part of that meeting
with the department of safety you know
our first our first
question of course was you know one of
safety is this
is this going to create is this going to
create an unsafe circum
situation out on the highways and you
know we
i was i was pleased to hear that they
they agreed that it
you know that is not going to happen
they believe that this
you know this what what is being
proposed is is
reasonable from a safety perspective and
so again i looked at that i said all
right safety we can check that box off
i look at the you know is it a precedent
are we setting a new precedent some kind
of crazy weight limit out there that's
not already
being hauled across the highways no i
look at what our neighboring states are
doing
and this would bring us in alignment and
consistent with those
um and so again for for us when we look
at this we say this just makes
it's just kind of a common sense
approach to this
um and we believe it's it
merits another look and again we
appreciate
the committee's review last time and the
favorable vote we would hope that you
would look favorably on this amendment
again
and with that i'll be happy to try to
answer any questions
thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
stock
um what does a trucker have to do if
they're coming in new hampshire
or through new hampshire with a heavier
load
that's that's a great that's a great
question representative because
they're they're not supposed to um so
the scenario back in february that i
gave was
i can load a truck in in white river
junction
and be legal i cross the connecticut
river
and on my axles i could be illegal
and then i'm going to a facility over a
wood yard in freiburg
as soon as i cross that main border i
can be legal again
and so really what what happens
to your point is if you're coming from
out of state into the state of new
hampshire
you're obligated to abide by our laws
and our weight limits
and um you're obligated to know what
those are
so when you load in white river junction
um you are supposed you know you're
obligated to know what our limits are
and abide by those so that's the
obligation on that truck driver
you can't follow up yep thank you um
so i'm assuming this would increase
delivery costs
wouldn't that then have an impact on the
commodity
in our state to our citizens
this would actually lower delivery costs
sorry i meant like what's going on right
now
yeah yeah i mean exactly this this would
this would make us more competitive with
our neighboring states
we're getting more we would be getting
in this case
you know a couple more tons 4 000 pounds
more
per load again i shouldn't say that
because
there are many instances where you are
hauling
99 000 pounds on that gross vehicle
weight
you are legal on a gross vehicle weight
but
your your drive axles because of the way
the load was
was you know when you loaded it up the
situation
you could still be illegal for actually
so we have instances where truckers
pull their hair out saying wait a minute
i loaded i was
99 000 pounds i thought i was doing a
good job
i get out on the highway i go through a
weigh station
and now i get i get tagged with an axle
overweight because my drives were over
the 30s
the current 36 000 and
you know that's a cost that is a cost to
the trucker and
it does affect the value of that
commodity thank you thank you mr
chairman
thank you i do have a couple of
questions and i'll get to the rest of
the committee
uh i you may have mentioned it and if
you did i apologize uh you mentioned
maine has the weight limit for the
tax away limit of 46 000 pounds
what was remarked i don't have vermont's
ahead of me when
in front of me i can certainly get that
when i talk to my
couple my truckers that haul over there
they said that vermont is
is comparable with maine's and that when
they configure their vehicles they
usually just use the main configuration
and then just out of curiosity what's
the uh
what's the violation fee how much are
these citations
uh if you violate this rule
this law that would be a good question
for for mr player i i know it's
i as i understand it there it has the
opportunity to escalate
but i think we're talking you know
hundreds
hundreds of dollars not tens of
thousands but that would be a good
question for
mr player fair enough i wish i thought
about it
um representative tillerson
thank you very much thank you mr stock
for taking my question
i had this question before your
testimony and you touched on it but i
didn't quite understand the answer
um you spoke about how they are um
they're loading these trucks in the
woods and you have the
loader on the crane say loading the raw
product and there are obviously no
scales
so how is it done is it done are you
literally eyeballing
the weight that's going into these
trucks and then
i assume you would be relying on the
experience
of the forestry workers as they do this
so can you please clarify
how these trucks are even being loaded
in the first place to meet these
these weight points sure
um and you kind of answered your your
question to some extent
it is it there a lot of it is experience
you watch you watch the truck's
suspension
as you load it um you
you watch the you know the suspension of
it
in the case of logs where you're loading
logs
you know you have an idea all right i'm
loading red oak today
i know i can go four logs high
you know i can go for you know three
tiers or four logs high when i load
when i load it into my onto the the back
of my truck
and so a lot of it is you you're looking
at
kind of the the experience level
um where things get really tricky
is on some of the seasonality
um in the spring of the year when sap is
flowing
you can have logs and chips that weigh
more
because you got a heavier wetter wood um
also talking to to loggers and
contractors
and truckers they'll say what will
happen is even on a particular woodlot
you may have a piece of land that you're
cutting and a section of it may be kind
of marshy and
in kind of heavier soils and kind of wet
the same trees same species of trees
being pulled off of that
just by virtue of growing in that wetter
soil
may be a little bit heavier so again
when they're loading it you're
constantly watching
and you know the you're constantly
watching trying to make sure that you
can get
as close to 99 000 pounds um
without going over and also recognizing
that to the extent that you can
try to hit these axle weights but again
given some of the variabilities
um and i've had truckers try with
onboard scales
and again they said what they'll tell me
what they've told me time and again is
you know onboard scales are good if
you're in a nice flat parking lot
or you know in a nice flat area with
solid surface but when you're out in the
woods
and your truck may be tilted a little
bit one way or the other
or those axles may be on a spot on that
log landing that's a little bit
softer than another spot they said the
onboard scales
really they they don't provide the
guidance that you would think
so a lot of it is experience and and
just
kind of trying to make sure that you're
you're doing what you're which what you
should be legally doing
thank you for that information you're
welcome
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you mr stock
um i'm just curious about
how you control load weights for a
material
that can shift like wood chips and how
you keep
the weight off the the axles um
as you're coming out of the woods and
you're bouncing around and the chips are
shifting
and to get those weights over the axles
right do you have to
warp at some of the load weight
for the truck overall and be below that
99 000
significantly yeah the
good question that the wood chips when
you're blowing them into the truck
the way they're loaded is typically
you'll have a chipper
with a spout at the back end of the
truck
and they blow them in um and one of the
challenges that you have with wood chips
is that as they blow in of course
they they can pack towards the nose of
the truck
which is your drive axles so contractors
what they'll do is they'll put sometimes
they'll put a sheet of plywood in there
or they'll aim they'll aim the blower um
on the on more towards the floor of the
truck so that you're not packing in the
nose of that trailer
and these are you know to to represent
telerescue's
point earlier these are techniques that
they try to use
to distribute that load once the load is
once the the trailer is is loaded the
chips really don't
they're not they're not going to flow
and move around
in it they really do tend to pack into
it
so you know logs they get strapped down
they stay put chips for the most part
they're not sloshing around or moving
around or shifting
they're when they get blown in they're
packing in
and again even with the techniques that
they use
you still have challenges of trying to
keep that that drive axle
under 36 000 pounds
do i see representative stephen's hand
up
representative stevens
you're muted
um this is a follow-up um
to the question that representative
polarsky
asked which is when you're in the woods
and you're loading up and there's no
scale and you go by all these
skills to determine your weight
when is the first opportunity to get
formally weighed in the process of
getting your product out
depending on yes that's a great question
and depending on where you're delivering
it
i mean many of your markets in your
mills
um some do have scales um
sawmills who buy on volume typically
don't
so it depends on on the market or the
skill
excuse me the market and whether they
have a scale or not
so it depends there are many instances
where a truck will leave a logging job
and go to a mill or a wood yard and not
even pass a scale
just because they're out in the middle
of the woods
literally and you know there just isn't
a scale
unless they travel you know many miles
out of their way to find a sand or
gravel pit or someplace with a certified
scale
so you know the there are instances
where depending on the market
it's just not practical unless you're
really having to go out of your way to
scale up a load
follow-up follow up
after you so there's no
advantage to being
weighed as soon as possible so that you
could correct anything
or how how how would you correct
like if you were over obviously not
under how would you correct
a problem at the first opportunity of
getting formally weighed
you just live with that mistake and then
get
get to your destination and pay the
fines along the way or
yeah it's a little bit of both uh you
know you'll you'll deliver a load
in the in the case of wood chips where
they're purchased on a per ton basis
you're going to have a you're going to
have a weight slip and you're going to
look at that you're going to say okay
and now that's a gross vehicle weight so
they're not going to look at the axle
weights and again this bill deals just
with axolotls
so they'll look at that and they'll say
oh okay you brought in
you know that that truckload brought in
you know
uh 90 you know 105 000 pounds
you were over okay i was chipping mostly
oak that day or some sugar maple
um i'm moving into a part of the stand
now or part of the woodlot that's all
pine
so i'll adjust i'll adjust my weight in
kind of
the amount of wood i should say the
amount of wood that i blow into it
in the case of logs um there are trucks
that and if you are hauling
there's pretty good in the case of logs
folks have a pretty good sense
if you're looking at a you know a 16
foot eastern white pipe
pine log 18 inches in diameter you know
again
there's some reasonable expectation of
what that log is going to weigh
and you do a count on your logs but even
then
many operators what they will do is
they'll do checks
though i may not pass a scale but what
i'll do is
the last load of the day i'll bring it
home and
i'll weigh it up you know at my shop at
home
and say all right how am i tracking um
again that's but you know what we're
looking at here in
both of those instances is gross vehicle
weight as opposed to axle weights
and so that's where again everyone
shoots to try to you know they're trying
to manage to that gross vehicle weight
uh target and this actually
what really gets tricky is when you're
looking at the specificity particularly
of those drive axles
thank you very much
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
chairman stark
uh for testifying today it's also my
school board chair
i um i will be voting in favor of this
amendment
uh but i had a quick question about uh
incrementalism
and whether um when we bump this
to 40 000 actual weight
whether we'll run into the same thing
with
with uh loaders trying to get right up
to that
40 000 that they do with the 36
000 now and it's a fault and the second
part of that question i wonder if you
knew the percentage
of time that they exceed this
this limit and how that relates to
maybe name with with their higher limits
does it
does it show a lower incidence of
exceeding that weight limit
i'll take your your last question first
um i don't have statistics on
on the exceedances um you know
i do know in maine you know when
talking to truckers that that are
operating in new hampshire
and operating in maine what they'll tell
me is
they are they are much more they are
consistently
compliant in the state of maine given
the given the
tandem weights there as opposed to new
hampshire
and so but i don't have raw statistics
on that
um the other piece though is the
incrementalism
and you know i guess what i what we
what we're looking at is you know we
look at this
we're dealing with a regional and we're
dealing with a very specific
commodity within this regional market
um you know if i'm i'm hauling
other commodities within you know i
don't know to what extent that
sand and gravel leaves the state or
stays in the state
but i know with forest products given
the nature of the product
given the nature of our marketplace and
the very regional nature of it
um this consistency piece is
is important and i would say
in many respects probably unique to us
in that
you know you're not there's very small
likelihood i could imagine where you
would be hauling say sander gravel
up to um you know skowhegan maine
um to a you know a mill in skowhegan
maine
from say milford new hampshire but
forest products
those go skowhegan maine they go over to
glens falls
you know they're moving all over because
that's where the mills are so i don't
think the incrementalism
you know for other commodities i don't
think we're going to see that
given the nature of the market again
that's my opinion
um you know i'm not in those other
industries but
clearly this is given the nature of our
markets
that's what we're seeing is they're
regional and the commodities have to go
where there's a willing buyer
thank you you're welcome representative
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
stock for your testimony which has been
pretty thorough this morning
i i wanted to ask you
or at least just clarify reiterate once
again
is new hampshire already letting
vehicles travel with an axle weight
higher than what this amendment proposes
on our roads yeah i
great question in in you know when i
again as i as i testified i took a look
when i when i kind of dove into 266
18b it really started to
unravel how these axle weights work and
looking at different trucking
configurations
you know again for a three axle single
unit
you're allowed 22 4 on a single axle
your gross vehicle weight can be 65 000
so again you take the you know you you
take the difference
so if i have a steering axle at 22 400
i back that off of my my my two rear
axles on that
three axle unit that's in excess of 40
000.
now and and the law is is pretty
specific to that
because there's there's also a provision
in there that
you know they say well it's it's 18 you
know there's a there's a provision under
266 18b roman 2b that says well you have
to have
18 000 18 000 pounds per axle
if they're if they're closer than 10
feet except
if it's a three or four axle single unit
so again
you get into these rules and kind of how
these
work it's pretty clear to me
that you do have vehicles already on the
road
with tandems at 40 000 pounds
um and again with the tri-axle example
uh i can i can have a a tri-axle
where the three the three axles in the
back
are 53 000 pounds but given the
allocation
of weight across those three axles i can
have two of those three
at 20 000 pounds again this is
this is a lay person trying to
but when i kind of go in and you do the
math and you look at the configurations
and you say geez
it's pretty clear to me that there are
already vehicles on our highways legally
with tandems at at this 40 000 pound
limit
um i again that's that's my read of it
and that's when i did the math and kind
of drew it drew it out on paper
that's what i came up with and that's
what it appears
thank you mr chair
thank you and so um
i believe that we already prohibit those
kinds of vehicles from traveling over
e2 bridges and are there any other
places where these
are prohibited from traveling
well yeah the law is clear um
and and this is this is in 266
18b that there the law is very clear
that
they cannot be driven over h15-44
bridges unless the
commissioner of the department of
transportation
actually authorizes them so there's
already restrictions
on these vehicles so you know
again and when we approached this we
looked at it from a safety perspective
and he says geez
we don't want to create you know if you
have a redless bridge out there
we don't i mean we want we need these
roads and bridges
just like everyone else we said geez we
don't want to tear them up
put any additional stress on but again
there's already a check in place
in the statute to that effect
thank you thank you very much for that
your mic's off any other questions from
the committee
seeing them thank you very much sir
thank you
it's a little sitter next up would be
mr david rodriguez
mr rodriguez are you on sir
yes thank you good morning mr chairman
and and members of the committee
the department has submitted could you
identify who you represent please
yes my name's david rodrigue
i'm the director of operations for new
hampshire department transportation
and thank you for hearing me this
morning the department has
submitted written testimony and i want
to
cover um three of our most significant
concerns
first i'm responsible
to provide weight posting for bridges
that cannot support legally loaded
vehicles
this this amendment would increase
the um axle loads for a very small
number of certified vehicles from 36
000 pounds to 40 000 pounds
the law already provides a 10 percent
buffer to bring folks over the limit
before they they are written a ticket so
this effectively
increases the the axle loads
um for a tandem axle to 44
000 pounds um traveling on our roads and
and bridges our this
this amendment applies to
rsa 266 18
b which is a special class of vehicles
which are our certified vehicles
when we raid our bridges we use the e2
posting to say this this bridge is not
suitable for a certified vehicle
should this amendment pass we will need
to re-rate
all of those bridges for what right now
is
a 40 000 pound um dual axle
load to a 44 000 pound
which will translate into more
e2 posted bridges that e2
posting will not just exclude these
these forestry trucks it will exclude
all of your your trucks that use these
two axle configurations
all of these certified vehicles so we
believe that would be an
unintended consequence of passing this
bill
a second concern is effective
axle weights on pavement damage
increases at an exponential rate which
means
when when you add an extra pound to an
axle it's not a
a linear increase to the the damage to
the pavement
it's an exponential increase so even a
modest
increase to the axle limits
of 11 that would translate to
one and a half times the damage to our
pavement that's
what you see in rutted pavement and in
cracked
pavement and and so forth
um so the effective axle weight
increases
has an exponential increase in the
damage
on our pavement and then i also wanted
to
uh address the notion um
and be very clear that passage of this
amendment um allowing heavier axle loads
will damage to our roads and
and bridges um i think there was some
misunderstanding in my original
testimony to this bill
um when i answered that we would not
necessarily
paved more frequently our pavement needs
are fiscally constrained not by
they're not constrained by the condition
of our pavement
um so the passage of this bill would
increase
damage to our pavements and bridges
um i do also want to ask
ask the folks on the committee to please
read rsa 266 18
b what you'll find is
sometimes um vehicles are limited
by their total weight gross vehicle
weight
and sometimes by their axle
weights it's my read of this that the
axle weights
are pretty consistently regulated at 18
000 pounds each or 36 000
pounds for a dual axle
so please pay attention to um
the wording in the law that will be
informative
to how you see this this change
and i would be happy to take any
questions
any questions for the committee member
representative barron mr chair
and thank you mr rodriguez for uh coming
and testifying this morning so
with regard to what you have been saying
does the 10 overage allowance that you
spoke about
apply to certified tri-axle trucks
and if so aren't you already inspecting
bridges
at that level that the bill allows
i'm sorry i don't understand yeah your
question
well you were saying that you know you
that that when you inspect the bridges
that you already allow for 10 overage
islands the
law the law allows for 10
over the limits that are set forth in
the law that is
that is correct and that's what we rate
the bridges up
okay but that that 10 percent overage
allowance also applies to certified
tri-axle trucks right
that is correct so are you
aren't you already inspecting oh good
aren't you already inspecting bridges at
that level
no we are not
okay so the the tri-axle
portion of the law that i read in 266
18-bit is um
number three and that refers to the
allowable
gross weight of a vehicle not the axle
loads
the allowable gross weight and that is
where the allowable gross weight of the
vehicle
for a tri-axle with three axles is 65
pounds that includes the steering axle
not just the tri-axle which are the
three axles in the rear of the vehicle
so it's really a poor axle vehicle
okay okay thank you thank you thank you
representative sykes
yes thank you mr chairman uh thank you
mr rodriguez for taking my question
at this point what i've heard from you
you seem to focus particularly on uh
bridges which
the state dot has you know um
an overriding interest to make sure that
they are safe but
my question to you is will not the
damage to the roads
it won't be uh specifically limited to
state roads and bridges but
in fact will also damage local roads
where local
municipalities would have to then bear
the brunt of its
of their repair absolutely
so again the poignant point in this
is a small 10 to 11
increase in weight translates to
a one and a half percent increase
to the damage to the pavement when it
comes to route
to rutting and cracking so
when we think of axle loads they're
really the
the concentration of of the load
at a single location which causes uh
the most damage when we talk about a
vehicle
a gross vehicle weight that weight
spread out over many axles and
and tires but axles concentrate the
the load at a specific place and that's
why we're
we pay very close attention to
limiting those axle loads to limit the
damage
to our roadways and bridges as a
follow-up mr chairman
certainly thank you
mr rodrigue my understanding
is that many of these trucks given the
rural
nature of the the business um
will be traveling on rural roads not the
interstate
am i correct in understanding that the
has a a lower limit for weights than
what that is that is contemplated in
this bill
that that is correct rsa 266 18
b for certified vehicles
is for weights on non-interstate
and general highway systems so these
these vehicles are not allowed it
allowed with some of these loads on the
interstate
thank you sir representative talarsky
thank you i put my hand up twice and
took it down because i my questions were
about municipal roads and i think
representative sykes hit them all thank
you
representative o'hara thank you mr
chairman just a quick question
um what'd you say the weight limit was
for e2 bridges
for the tri-axle or
so for like what were you guys scaling
it at
so so for the track first of all this
there's several different sections of
18b that that referred to tracks
tri-axles the portion i'm referring to
is 266 18b number three
that says the allowable gross weight of
a vehicle
um shall not be increased by the
addition
of trailing axles and so forth
and it says for a single unit three axle
vehicle
65 000 pounds that 65 000
pounds is a gross vehicle weight it's
not the weight of the triax so
it's not the weight on just those three
follow axles real quick sure uh when you
were talking about e2 bridges
yes did i hear you correctly when you
said it was 40
000 pounds you guys certified them at
i'm i'm sorry if if i was confusing
um when i explained that the the e2
posting is for all vehicles
that meet the requirement of section of
rsa 266 18 b
so it's no particular axle weight it's
no
particular gross vehicle weight it is
for
all the vehicles in this category which
is what creates the unintended
consequence
of this amendment to the law the the
this amendment to the law is creating
just
a a a small
or an exception for a very small number
of vehicles
which i believe is because the committee
understands that there
is increased damage so we don't want to
accept
all vehicles we just want to accept
these
these forest product vehicles from this
law
and give them the heavier axle weights
the unintended consequence of that is
there is no special bridge posting
for this new category of of trucks
that's being created
it's it's it's amending the law that
goes
and covers all certified vehicles that's
why
as we rerun this analysis for all
certified vehicles
it increases the number of e2 posted
bridges
which prohibits all all of the current
certified trucks from using those
bridges that will now be posted final
follow-up
one more follow it thank you um can you
tell me the
standard like the weights that you use
to certify a bridge e2
it it's what we come up with
is the most harshest loading
of any vehicle in the e2 posting
and we run that over each bridge
individually
it's a it's a significantly laborious
process that we go through our system
bridge by bridge
so right now where the the harshest
vehicle
may be that that dual axles
at 40 000 pounds now the harshest
vehicle will be those
that dual axles at 44 000 pounds
we then put together that that loading
plan
and we run that vehicle over all of our
bridges
and determine what additional bridges
need to be
e2 posted thank you thank you mr
chairman
representative barron thank you mr chair
and thank you again mr rodriguez for um
uh taking my question
so in hearing what you're saying and and
i
as i understand uh in maine
there uh tanner maxwell is
44 000 in vermont i believe it's 50.
um i'm just
wondering based on what you're saying
then is it that our roads and bridges in
new hampshire
are not built to the same standard as
those in vermont
maine and massachusetts perhaps
thank you very much for your question if
i may
i i queried vermont in in
in maine so why did not get into the
details of their laws
what uh what i have from vermont is from
captain kevin andrews
who's the chief of safety so
what vermont has is a divisible
load permit that allows any five
axle vehicle that has 51
feet between extreme axles
to permit to 90 000 pounds
our limit is 99 000 pounds
their limit for this part of the law is
90 000
pounds in this it goes on to say
this permit does not have any specific
axle weights so because they limit it to
000 pounds they don't measure the
the axle weights this goes on to explain
that vermont has a divisible load permit
that allows any six axle vehicle
that is 51 feet between extreme axles
to permit to 99 000 pounds
this permit requires a vehicle abide
by axle limits and number one above
and when we go to number one above the
axle limits for tandem axles is 36
000 pounds the same as new hampshire
is today so when i read vermont's law
i i do see that they don't have axle
limits
for a vehicle loaded to 90 000 pounds
but they still do have axle limits
that are consistent two hours for
vehicles
up to 99 000 pounds which is what our
certified load
law requires maine is another story
so maine excludes
all of their commodities so maine has a
weight tolerance for certain vehicles
and they go on to explain that a vehicle
loaded
entirely with building materials that
absorb
moisture during delivery and they go on
box sawdust firewood
sod lumber dimension lumber pulp wood
wood chips logs
soil unconsolidated rock material
including limestone bolts farm produce
rock salt manufacturers concrete
products
solid waste or incinerator ash dump
trucks or transit mix
conch and they they go on and accept
all the vehicles not just a small
portion
but uh we're we're not changing the
allowable gross
weight of the vehicle though we're just
adjusting how much weight can be
distributed among the axles
yes representative that is correct and
my point is
it's that additional weight to the axles
that causes the most damage to our roads
that were not built
to sustain those weights a modest
10 percent increase to the axle load
increases the damage by one and a half
times
thank you any other questions for this
witness
mr chair go ahead
thank you mr robert for taking the
question
does the department of transportation uh
keep statistics on
commercial
sorry i'll start over perhaps you
couldn't hear me thank you mr roderick
for taking the question
does the department of transportation
keep statistics on the volume of
commercial trucking in the state the
number of movements
and if so i'd be curious to know what
percentage of
of the commercial trucking is
commercial vehicles carrying rare
forestry products um
i'm curious to know what kind of numbers
we're talking about here in the
relationship the total number of
trucking in the state if you
may know that thank you
you're welcome thank you for your
question we we do not
keep those those statistics
um i don't know if the the department of
safety may have something on that
we do not have those statistics i would
say
i i will very quickly concede that this
is a relatively small number of
vehicles um but the law that we're
changing
is the office for certified loads again
and increases that that number of
vehicles
we have to radar bridges and our roads
um for those harshest loads
thank you anyone else
seeing none you have one up
representative i'm sorry i can't say his
last name
thank you representative thank you thank
you thank you mr chairman thank you mr
rodriguez um just
one quick question how many bridges um
would be affected by this how many
bridges would would you estimate would
no longer
be able to carry these loads
we will have to do the analysis to
to answer answer that question so
there's
there's a a couple thousand bridges that
that we would run through
um my my guess is it's going to be in
in the low dozens not in in the hundreds
um but any of those bridges that get
posted
and prohibit the the other trucks have a
significant impact
on moving goods and materials in our in
our state
anyone else see none
thank you for your testimony mr rodrigue
thank you sir
thank you
recognizes uh jeff aims in support of
the bill
representing himself
well good morning can everybody hear me
you can okay for the record my name is
jeff
eames i'm a resident of epsom new
hampshire we own a business
called four mountain trucking four
mountain companies
which is in allenstown new hampshire to
learn a little bit more about us you can
visit our website
at new hampshire forestry.com
um we have seven trucks that are
registered in the state we employ
six drivers two mechanics along with
seven other people that work in the
woods
as we mentioned i'm here to support
amendment 14
42 for a number of different reasons
in our forestry operations we try to be
as friendly as possible to a piece of
ground and minimize the impact
of you know a log landing an area where
we're going to
load trucks in order to get a real good
you know idea of how much that truck
weighs we need to have a very level
piece of ground
even with onboard scales we've loaded
trucks
that appear to be legal according to our
axle weights we come down
onto the level ground and we're off
um in order to remedy this
for us it would be expensive to excavate
the same time there we'd be leaving a
larger log landing
and we tend to mix up the soils which
prevents
natural regeneration is how a forest you
know
will start to grow 75
of our customers are in maine we support
a wood chip business a fuel pellet
business
and a large sawmill in sanford
so transporting in new hampshire and
then going to maine
you know maine seems a little bit a
little bit more
it's the word i'm looking for
accommodating and understanding
you know how things happen in the forest
with
know different weight axle
configurations in the sense of how we're
going to load that truck
um and i guess to the best of my
understanding
20 years ago plus when they increased
the weight limits to certified loads
they never increase the axle limits
to compensate for that increase the way
other states have
that's the best of my understanding i
tried to do some research on that
but i really couldn't come up with
anything
concrete but i would like to do some
more research on that and get back to
the
committee regarding that
um i guess for the most part
that's all i need to add or want to add
i'd be happy to answer any questions
that everyone has
especially as far as loading trucks i
know there's some questions about
loading trucks and getting a flavor for
how much the truck weighs
thank you any uh questions from the
committee
it's being done thank you again sir
all right thank you
see uh last person i have signed up in
advance to testify
is there anybody online that cares to
speak to this boat
uh does it matter uh
okay am i unmuted you are good morning
all right
well good morning the record uh this is
representative howard pearl
i was the original sponsor of uh house
bill 279 which is now
currently the amendment before you that
you're listening to
you've had some great testimony today
and you had great dialogue
with all of the uh the people that uh
you know you've had come in and i
appreciate certainly all of the interest
that this bill is taking
i'm just going to quickly kind of
summarize the points and the reason that
i put the bill in
in the original bill i was
contacted by the forestry industry
specifically members of the forestry
industry that are really having an issue
with this
they're they're doing their best to
comply with the gross vehicle weights
but they're running into issues hitting
this axle gross axle weight
and so we looked at this bill uh when i
originally looked at it with jason stock
and um
and bob scully from the new hampshire
motor transport and we decided we would
go and have a meeting with
the department of safety and uh with the
commissioner and
we went through all of the things that
he would heard
you know and safety found that there was
no issue i certainly recognized that the
d.o.t has a concern about
the quality of the roads and the
condition of them and we all do it's
important
but you have to remember these folks are
paying already paying an additional fee
to haul this extra weight and when they
get stopped and get hung up on a
technicality like this where they're not
on their
overweight on their aggregate but
they're overweight on their axle it just
causes
an onerous burden for them to continue
to try and operate
and as you heard in testimony what is
already a very narrow mark
for them on profitability so like
d.o.t you know also testified in the
department transportation excuse me that
you know this is a very small amount of
the cargo that's transported over the
roads
you're not going to make an enormous
difference in my opinion in the uh
the amount of wear and tear that are on
these roads for the most part
these weights are already on the roads
it's just these guys are absorbing the
fines and dealing with it and it's
really hurting them because they can't
meet the current um the current level on
a regular basis so
these weights are already on the road
the damage that is is already occurring
in many instances because they're doing
their best but they're finding
themselves in violation
and i guess if it was such a major issue
i i think you'd find that other states
who
are having a heavier axle weight such as
maine
would not be allowing it because their
roads are very similar eyes so i'll just
quickly wrap up i know this has run a
long time
this hearing has i appreciate chairman
walsh and all of you on the committee
reconsidering
this as an amendment to a another bill
so that we can
move this forward i realize it's a small
group of people but i will tell you it's
a very important group of people within
our state
as far as you know keeping the
our forest land management in the good
order that it is
and i think it's really important that
you pass this bill again as you did last
time
so thank you very much thank you many
questions from the committee
see you again thanks again i'll do one
more last call anybody else
to speak to this amendment
seeing that public hearing on
amendment 1442.
okay i'll get right logger and i thought
i was going to
what i'm going to do
i'm going to open the executive session
on senate bill 131
i sent out i just want to check with
members of the committee
we're going to be dealing with four
amendments to this has everybody
received
all of them this is one of them 14 42.
there's three options i can get the
numbers if you wish
mr chairman can you just adjust the mic
again a little bit closer thank you okay
i'm just trying to make sure that
everybody in the committee has received
uh copies of all the amendments uh 1442
which we just heard
is one of them um there's an amendment
actually let me get the numbers from the
clerk if you said i'm handy
uh 1442 1536
1536 is an amendment to part six
1528. 1528 has seven amendments apart
well i'm just going to my notes here
1372.
everybody i just there's a couple people
here that are missing
uh i can deal with them in person i just
want to make sure that
uh everybody that's remote has all these
because i am going to recess this
for a brief period so we can we can all
have a conversation
representative sykes
thank you mr chairman i had a question
about process
for you my assumption
is that you're going to take up each of
these amendments
individually and will vote up or down on
each amendment
and then ultimately get to a status
point for
senate bill 131 that we will then vote
as a whole
is that that is correct i had
it originally looked at uh maybe seeking
ols
to do just one amendment with all the
parts but it started to get way too
complicated uh so i figured i'd just
we'll take them one at a time
okay thank you i appreciate that and
then you you mentioned you're going to
take
a recess is that for caucus purposes or
is that for just a break
it's a caucus purpose well call it both
if you'd like but
use the time for a caucus if you choose
the first that hearing went longer than
i
anticipated so it did thank you mr
chairman
uh we're not saying i don't see no hands
from anybody remote so i'm assuming
everybody's got the uh all the
amendments
um so brad excuse me
some of us
okay that being said well i'm going to
recess until
a quarter of
order of 11. so brad if you can shut us
down to a quarter of 11
and post that we're in recess
if my colleagues could check their
emails i'll send a zoom link
this
representative do you know what happened
to to uh
representative uh i just talked to her
oh okay
representative rich is having trouble
finding her link to the meeting if you
wouldn't mind resending it
looks like she's in the attendees i'm
promoting her now
there she is thank you very much
opening up the executive session on
senate bill 131
chair recognizes representative gagne
for a motion
thank you mr chairman gemini sb 131
fn off to pass
[Music]
thank you mr chairman
i move out to pass on amendment 1536h
motion to move for amendment 1536
second second
yeah just real quick all this is doing
is adding
these vehicles into the decal
so it's bought and leased
uh this was a good catch by
representative
any discussion on this amendment
i think the only discussion i would have
mr chairman is that i believe this was
something that the
sponsor of the of the bill was in full
accord with and
it seems like it would be a good thing
to add to amend
thank you for that and it also matches
the language of the firefighter specific
sentence regarding that fair enough uh
with no further discussion on the
amendment i'll ask the clerk to call
the motion on the floor is to adopt the
member 1536
vice chairman gagnon uh vice chairman
gagne
yes clerk votes yes
representative smith yes representative
hill
yes representative aaron yes
representative
torrenson yes representative
yes representative o'hara yes
representative johnson yes
representative sykes
yes representative perez
yes representative rossi
yes representative pickering yes
representative rich yes representative
toloroski
yes representative fox yes
representative stevens
sorry yes thank you representative
yes and chairman walsh yes
is that 18 or not 19. 19-0
okay so
bill is still open to further amendment
chair recognizes
representative smith thank you mr chair
i move amendment 2021 15-28
second second second second
senator motion
thank you mr chair this amendment
deletes
sections three and four of part one
section three is uh allowing
municipalities to
establish a tax credit for folks that
install
electric charging units right now there
are federal programs to incentivize
people to buy
charges and there may be other programs
also the utilities stand to make quite a
bit of money with the increased
volume and sales so why disincentivize
them from providing it right now
but this hasn't really been rolled out
so i think it's premature to establish
tax credit
section four establishes rate design
standards
since we haven't reasonably deployed
enough charging units yet to get an idea
of the market i think it's premature to
do this right now
thank you discussion representative
thank you mr chairman um so
i i can get i can get behind uh taking
out
uh section four because the
one of the prime sponsors of the the
legislation was
good with that he understood there were
some questions about that that needed to
be answered and so
we're i'm i'm all good with part four uh
section four is the section three take
eliminating the
uh tax incentive part that gives me
pause
and um it's hard it's unfortunate that
the two have been
mixed together because i could support
one and not support the other and
move things along as it stands now i
probably want to vote against the
amendment
the reason i would do this is because we
new hampshire is already behind
the charging station wars if you will
and it's really important for us to
incentivize
um private industry to
put these high either high speed or just
regular speed charges into our
infrastructure for the state
and it is only enabling legislation it's
not like
not all communities will choose to give
this tax break
and i think it's important to let local
cities and towns
have their say about whether they want
to work as hard as they can to get
more charging stations in their
communities and for that reason i'll
vote against the amendment as it is but
would
would uh certainly be pleased to vote
for the amendment that takes out part
four uh section four only
thank you further
my question would be why should i a
non-vehicle driver
pay my tax money to go to someone to
incentivize a business to
[Music]
i guess i could answer representative
gagne's question
um in this way if private businesses put
in
charges that result in
more availability for these charges and
that brings more
tourists more regular shoppers more
family members to your community because
they they need the charger to get there
that will in fact improve the business
climate and the personal climate for
many many
individuals within a community and i
think that
type of discussion is best left to the
local communities rather than the state
representative thank you mr chairman um
my only thoughts are
if this is going to bring more tourists
and
money to the businesses why do they need
a tax cut anyways
uh just a question of the chair uh if a
part is removed uh
does that allow are we allowed under
house rules to bring that back up next
uh
next session
thank you
mr chairman i can't hear your response
we should have stayed in our other room
i guess we've finally gotten the bugs
worked out
any better so so because there is no
itl on this this would be able to come
back
as a separate bill single bill next year
believe that to be correct yes thank you
uh any further discussion from the
committee on amendment
for my my notes who's second to none
thank you okay seeing none i'll just
turn in a little bit here
um i do concur that section four was
agreed to by the prime sponsor to be
removed
as being premature um i also feel
uh part three is premature but even
beyond that i just have a
fundamental issue with potentially
probably not even potentially
raising taxes on a certain group of
people
uh just to benefit another group of
people based on their choices
of personal transportation so i'll be
supporting
this amendment as well um that being
said with no other discussion
i will ask you to call the role the
motion on the floor
is to adopt amendment 15 28.
thank you uh vice chairman gagne
yes clerk votes yes
representative smith yes representative
hill yes
representative aaron yes representative
torreson
yes representative gorski
yes representative o'hara
yes representative johnson yes
representative sykes
no representative perez
no representative gracie
no is that a pickering no
represented rich
no representative fox no
representative stevens no
representative no chairman walsh
yes adopted
pending i should say okay uh bill is
still open to further amendment
uh the chair recognizes
mr chairman mr chairman
i would move
amendment 2021-1442-h
has ought to pass
second by representative aaron after an
hour and a half is there any more
discussion on this amendment
[Laughter]
would you just remind by name rather
than just amendment number
the amendment that's under discussion
because then i may have
further conversation can can you repeat
that i'm sorry i represent sex
yeah that's okay um so this is the
amendment about forestry products
i wanted to be clear about that yes yes
this is the amendment
this is the non-germain amendment we
heard this morning at nine o'clock
uh relative to maximum actual weights
the bill that uh did pass this committee
13-6
as amended uh and missed it on the house
floor by
three votes actually so uh that's that's
that's the bill all right well
thank you you i i would make uh the
following observations mr chairman
thanks for giving me in a moment
um i i am very anxious about adding an
amendment
to a body of work that
um i can get behind in support
specifically senate bill 131
we're going to be making some good
changes to the to the senate bill and i
you know i'm looking forward to
supporting the final version that we
have
my concern is that
even surprising me the full house voted
down and went against the committee's
recommendation on the
bill this amendment being the same
on the floor of the house and i'm
worried that
all those people who wouldn't support
the bill
in its by itself will then transfer
that lack of support to the overriding
good that we're trying to accomplish
with with senate bill 131
and for that reason i'm i'm going to
vote against the amendment because i
think it's a
i i fear that it is a poison pill that's
being added
unintentionally but that it's being
added to the
to the senate bill 131
thank you point point taken um
i gave a lot of consideration before i
decided to add
this amendment i was in conversations
with a lot of people and i discovered
that there was some misunderstanding
uh about the bill uh prior to it being
voted on
uh on house session so
uh understanding there's always a chance
when you add things
i looked at this bill as a bill that we
passed as a committee
part of my job is to defend our
committee reports uh in spite of all the
hard work that was done to the rest of
i started fit to uh to add this keep in
mind that
these these omnibus bills are not my
favorite thing to do either
uh hopefully i will never see one of
these things ever again
so uh anybody else
would like to speak to 130 coming out to
this amendment
seeing then i'll ask the court to call
the rule
vice chairman yes clerk votes yes
representative smith
yes representative hill yes
representative aaron
absolutely yes representative torrance
yes representative yes
representative o'hara yes representative
johnson
yes representative sykes no
representative perez
no representative grassy
no representative pickering yes
representative rich no
presenter no
representative fox no
representative stevens yes
representative value yes
chairman walsh yes
six 13 26
okay the amendment uh is adopted at 16 6
same as it was last time um i only have
one
more amendment uh
proposed uh would you like to make the
most
representative thank you very much i
would i'd like to
make a motion to accept amendment number
2021-1372h
if i may speak to that all right again
second second if i represent erosion uh
i wish to speak to it sure
i i would um this is
pretty clear cut when i saw this
that it's an ancient dinosaur that's
been forgotten
in the statutes that
the disabled community is called out as
separate from all others in the granite
state when it comes to non-photo
or non-driver picture identification
cards um
i believe this is a perfect opportunity
to tell our disabled granite staters
that they are
every part uh the same as the rest of us
and this amendment simply strikes
um the line that disabled people who do
not have a driver's license can get
a photo id they're already covered under
section a
so um i hope everyone could support this
bill
in the united front to affirm uh our
disabled
residents that they are every part a
member of our community and it did have
the
approval of uh senator waters and
director belocky
so thank you thank you any further
discussion from the committee
seeing none i concur with everything
representative said
so i'll ask the clerk to call the world
vice chairman gagney yes clerk voties
representative smith yes representative
hill yes
representative aaron yes representative
torreson
yes president yes
susan o'hara yes representative johnson
yes
representative grassy yes
yes representative rich yes
yes representative fox yes
and stevens
so i remember 1372 and uh the
motion on the floor senate bill 131
amendment i do not have any other
amendments for me
does anybody else have any seeing none
uh again the motion on the floor is
yes thank you um i i
for the most part pleased with the work
that we've that's taken place with these
amendments today
and i would urge my colleagues to vote
in favor of senate bill
131 as amended
further discussion
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
role as soon as she's ready
hi sharon
yes representative yes representative
aaron
yes representative harrison yes
yes representative o'hara
yes represent johnson yes
yes representative perez yes
representative brassy yes
pickering yes representative rich
yes tellerski
representative fox yes
stevens yes representative
yes chairman walsh yes 19-0
who made that motion
any objections
actually the fiscal notes have been
mostly stripped out okay
because as we remove things out of
section one
kind of eliminator as you're not
objecting
well we're going to go on consent unless
we're told otherwise
so okay that closes the executive
session on senate bill 131
and just a couple other items before we
go
first of all i'd like to thank all of
you for putting up with me today this
was not my test day
it's been a long long week with very
little sleep
um congratulations to everybody we got
through it
uh interesting year and i want to thank
everybody
the only thing we've got left to address
uh as we move on are some of the bills
that have been retained
uh i talked to a few of the people that
uh the prime sponsors
at this point um
they're gonna do some work and some
research on them on their own
and as i get some information from them
i'll start calling some uh
full committee work sessions uh for
anybody that's interested
uh i'll go so far unless there's
somebody that specifically like to
volunteer for the creation
of a subcommittee on any of the retained
bills we have
that's mr chairman can
i want to make sure i understood what
you said so
some of the time sponsors of the bills
that have been retained are going to do
some work and get back to you
in the meantime as that happens you may
in fact
call back the whole committee to vote on
these bills
well no what i want to do is as i get
some information from some of the
sponsors that i'm actually expecting to
do some of the work themselves they're
their bills
uh when i do get that information i'll
reach out to the committee
uh possibly schedule some full committee
work sessions
and if you can make it you can and if
you don't want to participate you don't
have to
uh we can't be voting on this until
later on in the year
okay so there'll be work sessions as
opposed to subcommittees okay that's
that's the part i was trying to get
clear in my head thank you uh no they'll
be voluntary
uh again unless there's a particular
bill that's retained that somebody wants
to volunteer now
who would like to see a subcommittee
form i think this is the best way to go
at this point
sounds good fair enough i have nothing
else if there's any questions from
anybody
now's the time nope
seeing none thank you again very much uh
we'll see you on june
3rd
it's my birthday